It's the biggest timber-frame structure in the world...
...according to those who built it.
The length of almost two football fields, seven storeys tall,...
...Ark Encounter is crafted according to the Bible's description of Noah's Ark,...
...supposedly built at God's command...
...to escape a flood that drowned the world.
Well, back to my writing.
Inside, visitors can meet an animatronic version of Noah himself,...
...whom the scripture says was aged 600 at the time.
I'm documenting some of the terrible things...
...that happened before the flood.
The vessel also holds models of the animals, two of each kind,...
...that Noah took aboard.
And we've really given people the big picture...
...with an emphasis on the ark and the flood in particular.
These particular believers may be small in numbers,...
...but according to a recent Gallup poll, some four in every ten Americans...
...do agree that the earth was created within the past 10,000 years.